darina is there another like moment or
scene that sort of like i guess
tipped you over the edge of hatred well
since you just mentioned the whole scene
with the afterlife let's start
with why jack could it fit
on the massive plank oh yes
we're gonna talk about this and i know
it's been debated and i know
mythbusters i believe even made an
episode about it james cameron replied
to them
and said i don't care jack had to die we
know what james cameron was trying to do
here
however there's even people that have
done this
where they both fit perfectly well on
the
massive plank and they're even playing
cards and on top of that rose had the
life jacket when she could have given it
to jack
so i don't understand any of that scene
i was very angry by then
because i was already angry at the fact
that it was three hours and a half and i
really had to pee and there was no
intermission for some reason during this
movie
uh in mexico at least and so i mean
i'll never let go girl you did let go
and you also let go of the necklace
worth millions of dollars that could
have helped the earth
that's another thing that pissed me off
so it's all related and also talking
about the afterlife scene specifically
so we're supposed to think that she's
going to end up with him in heaven
and they all uh welcome her what about
grandpa
what about like where is rose's
old lady's husband like that thing
she's supposed to see him for like two
oh sorry continue jacqueline
i actually think it's jack's baby like i
didn't see
how many kids they only show one kid
right and one grandchild
oh okay so you're saying that jack got
her pregnant and
okay but still i got to side with doreen
on this then because
it's still then this guy was living with
was married to her
presumably loved her and was raising a
kid that he might have
known wasn't his but i don't know how
often can you imagine being like the
rebound
and just hearing about this watery jack
all day and night she probably calls him
jack in the bedroom and he's like hey
honey you did it
back again and and she's probably into
like weird fetishes like no
let's get ourselves in freezing cold
water and then make love and and he's
like
honey you got off the ship okay i'm not
gonna keep doing this
i love the idea of rose being like a
cold water
fetishist oh where is that movie
hey i bet it's been made i bet it's been
made
well there's that great song that paint
did
about like what happens to the brit
disney princesses after happily ever
after and like
people accusing belle of bestiality and
the fact that jasmine is probably like
uh aladdin's probably locked up for
terrorism so i'm
about seeing the unhappily ever after
of what happens with rose after she like
maybe maybe she does have
maybe she only has sex in the back of
cars that's true
but also i mean what about like like is
do you think grandpa
is just waiting in heaven like where is
she
she just died she's supposed to be here
who is this jack guy that
apparently she's reuniting with that she
only knew for two days and also
i didn't know she had all this money on
this jewel she threw in the ocean and i
had to help support our kids and she
just threw a bunch of millions of
dollars
in the ocean and she just kept it to
herself this entire time
so just saying also how was she like
financially appended she walked off that
boat with a jacket
and a and a diamond and she was just
like living life without having to sell
that that diamond lasts
a day
[Music]
you